please welcome Kirsten Dunst and Orlando
Bloom
there is a long-standing belief in
Hollywood that some of the finest films
ever made were made in the editing room
the tools of the trade are continually
changing nothing can ever replace the
skill and judgment of the professional
in charge of the process the film editor
and here are the academy award worthy
nominees for this year
Thelma Schoonmaker for The Aviator
Jim Miller and Paul Rubel for collateral
Matt Jessie for Finding Neverland Joel
Cox for Million Dollar Baby
hold us for right
and the award goes to the Oscar goes to
Thelma Schoonmaker for the Aviator this
is the second Academy Award and fifth
nomination for Thelma Schoonmaker
she won in this category for Raging Bull
um thank you so much uh this is really
as much yours as it is mine Marty not
only because you helped me edit the
movie but because you think like an
editor when you shoot and you gave us an
incredibly dazzling ride on this film
and gave us a fantastic group of actors
I truly loved editing your footage and
there's there are so many people to
thank I won't thank them but I think
they know who they are the mixers the
wonderful visual effects people but
particularly my assistants Scott Brock
Tom Fellini oh and Aaron crackle they
really got it up there on the screen
but it's really you Marty to you thank
you
you